foreign
hey you guys what's going on it's Friday
and it's time for another one of these
discussions
I got the Dracula's bed and breakfast
sign on yeah well I had to buy I had to
buy a um what do you call those things
the attention cord yeah extension cord
yeah I'm getting mad cow disease I'm
getting like holes like uh chewed into
my brain because I can't like remember
[ __ ] but yeah well the thing about it
was that all of those colored lights
over there
um they already took up all the plugs
like big time so I actually the
extension cord I had to plug it in way
over there I had to plug it away over
there
good thing I got a 15 foot long one yep
because otherwise it wouldn't reach Zach
says so today was officially my last day
at my awful old job and when I left I
felt like Nicole Kidman in those
pictures when she signed the divorce
papers from Tom Cruise wait they got
pictures of that I need to see that I
need to see some like Google evidence of
that which she just like sitting there
going yes
I take away from this freak that's a lot
better I turn that fan on yeah it's hot
in here because the sun's going down
over there well yeah it's weird because
usually it's really cold in here that's
why I have like a jacket all the end of
the day the sun's setting right there
but yeah it does kind of go outside like
this yeah because it's coming in the uh
the bathroom because I mean the windows
over there's two windows but I always
keep those the curtains over them so
today is basically open lines Friday
we'll talk about whatever you guys want
to talk about we'll sit here we'll drink
and uh we may be going to mannequins
tonight
maybe I'm in mood all right I could go
I'll see how I feel yeah so I mean you
have to give me like a little bit of
time to yeah we'll have to shut the show
down a little bit early I mean I have I
already know if we go I already know
what I would wear probably although I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do
with my hair I don't really feel like
we're just waiting but no you know we're
awake okay well it's just too hot and it
gives me like a headache if I wear them
too long you know what I mean
because if you wear them out you have to
like clip them underneath here and it
gives me a headache it's not hot outside
though
it wasn't today
I think it only I think it only got to
eight well yeah my computer says it's
82.
which is
that's like that's like winter yeah
most of the day was 15 degrees
what's up Dave hello you two he says
yeah you're probably going to Mana kids
we might go to oh my God I don't know we
might go later like I said it doesn't if
I mean if we whenever we shut the show
down if we still feel like going like um
you know it's not like we have to get
there at any particular time or anything
like that but yeah we haven't been to
mannequins in a really long time no
and I mean I guess that's just because
it's weird because mannequins is closer
yeah than Barbarella but Barbarella is
easier to get to because you can go
there like on total uh what do you call
those things toll roads toll roads see
she doesn't know how to say well now I'm
having like a hard time like remembering
stuff today I don't really know why like
I said let me check the bank situation
uh Dave said it should be a fun one
today what is the theme tonight I'm sure
it has a theme and I'm sure I probably
did the poster for it but I do so many
posters that I don't remember and I was
gonna say too that this weekend is
Absolution in Tampa
like the goth Festival but because they
asked um Mark Paradise asked if we were
going and I was like well I don't know
because that's kind of a long drive I
mean
they'd let us in for free but
Zach says I just sent Tom the pictures
on Facebook it's hilarious the ones of
Nicole Kidman divorcing Tom Cruise the
divorce papers
murder Hornet said can we talk about
fleshlights I mean if you like I don't
really have any experience with them but
I'm sure some people do laughs
[Music]
um
oh it's cyberpunk tonight oh is it
that's right yeah yeah I did that poster
I remember that
like I said I do the posters but I I do
like usually Tina will ask me to do like
a batch of them at a time like two or
three at a time so I don't like remember
what the dates are
you know what I mean because they
usually like to have like a different
thing every Friday and uh it just all
kind of runs together
uh murder Hornet said just laying here
shooting smack okay well hey you do you
this peach vodka is actually pretty good
yeah it's not bad I'm not usually like a
big fan of peach things but um but it's
good with uh orange juice That's
supposed to be Nicole Kidman
getting divorced from Tom Cruise I
believe it that's it
hysterical well I especially I
especially like will show me oh well
never mind what I especially like that
one yeah because she just looks like
I'm free
hahaha
Dave says by the way you kick ass on
them posters too well thank you very
much I do try to like make cool looking
ones I never really I never really you
know you look at Nicole Kidman and that
to me that just doesn't look that just
doesn't look like a like a Tom Cruise
girlfriend she looks too tall and pale
you know and I know it I always kind of
got the impression that Nicole Kidman I
don't know I don't know her obviously
like I've only seen her in movies and
stuff and I think she's a great actress
but she seems to me like someone that
wouldn't put up with his [ __ ] she
doesn't seem like this well that's one
way of putting it but she also doesn't
seem to be any fun to me well neither
does he
yeah it's just in a different way yeah
he's probably pretty oh yeah yeah of
course yeah of course man let's do it
yeah
I don't know I don't know
according to science well I don't want
to say according to scientologists
because look and they're all going to
tell you but according to things that
I've heard come out of the Scientology
scene
the closest the closest thing he had to
a body
was David miscavige and David's
miscavage
talked about it behind his back like
like he was a douche
I mean in David miscavige's defense
which is the only time I'm ever going to
say this because he has also chode yeah
but
um Tom Cruise probably is a douche so
even a stop clock is right twice a day
that's some kind of short guy thing
going on it's like a short guy Mafia if
you're short you know what I'm talking
about they're in the [ __ ] shorts are
you in it Tom yeah [ __ ] right dude it
sure runs the local chapter you sure got
Mafia you throw a bunch of short guys
together then all of a sudden they're
buddies and [ __ ] but they're kind of
like little people like you know it's a
play word for you know like dwarves and
[ __ ] where they got to be the only one
then they start hating on each other
there's too many of them they start
hating on each other
yeah we've told that story before too
because we we have a friend who's a
little person yeah and his name is Tito
he works and works at Universal he works
the universal I guess he still does and
he uh he works at um he's hilarious
ASPCA too I think yeah he's hilarious um
yeah he's like yeah he's awesome but the
funny thing is that for a little while
like when ibar was still ibar there was
another little person who we didn't know
who's younger who was younger and he
started coming there too and man Tita
would get so pissed like every time he's
like there's that other [ __ ]
what's wrong man
what's wrong what's wrong another little
point that the other guy on the dance
floor and he goes
I hate him what's the problem
because you don't understand man because
he's Latino you don't understand man
there can be only one that can't be only
one he's hilarious little people are
like yeah yeah like that and he won if
there's another one in the area they
don't like it because yeah well they're
taking all the attention they're taking
all the attention away
but that guy I only saw that other guy
we never met the other guy no three or
four times I only saw him like three or
four times and nobody like yeah whereas
like everybody knows who Tito is but
because he's kind of like a regular yeah
Tito would be like come on man I don't
want to get you in trouble but
if you throw me off the top
because there's two levels yeah
because you know there's like an upper
floor to the club and then there's a
dance floor this is this is over the old
at the old place yeah old uh independent
bar
and he was like we'll get somebody to
catch me you know he's he and you know
because he's always he was he's an
acrobat yeah and Anna uh
and dresses dresses up as Ewoks you know
for [ __ ] and all different other kind
of characters at Disney
it put him in his costume so he does
Disney and universally because he I know
he was a Minion for a while yeah right
he is so he he was an actor kind of in
the show business you know
so he did not want to be he had to be
the center of attention
did you understand that
yeah I get it yeah he so he wanted he'd
get drunk and he'd start try to invent
his head how he was going to steal the
attention from the
from the entire club by jumping off the
second floor balcony of the club onto
the Dance Floor
[Laughter]
she wanted me to throw him
throw away
and then we have somebody else catch him
and he was like
[ __ ]
when a guy was catching him he'd roll
off his back or something and roll and
then come out and do like a ta-da across
the dance floor because he was an
acrobat
yeah he had it all planned out get it
all planned and he was like I don't want
you to get in you and I don't want to
get you in trouble you don't have to
throw me you you catch me
[Laughter]
[ __ ] funny
yeah uh I haven't seen Taylor in a long
time
yeah yeah
so I'm trying to re I'm reviewing this
in my head I can't believe that it
didn't happen
because it probably should happen
trouble
I could imagine his drunk ass jumping
off the top [ __ ] balcony doing a Swan
Dive and my drunk ass tried to catch him
and that [ __ ] going wrong I think that
probably would have worked right yeah
very badly yeah I mean that's it's far
you know what I mean I mean you would
definitely I don't know if you
necessarily die but you would probably
break a whole bunch of Bones and he
wasn't light he weighed what a man
weighed he just had short arms and legs
yeah
you know and that dance floor was like
hard you know what I mean so if he like
jumped off like and also there was that
kind of little stage situation that had
kind of like the metal bars on it if you
landed on that
yeah you'd be in big trouble you'd
probably like break your back yeah I
would imagine
he had a normal sized body and
everything he just had short arms and
legs
and he I get sick of [ __ ] talking
down to him at the when he's standing up
the bar remember so I'd grab a damn
chair yeah make a standing in a chair
it's [ __ ] funny
they're so mean though
he's like I can't help it like I can't
help myself I remember I put him up on
it I put him up on a block or something
yeah but he's [ __ ] funny you know it
didn't matter so you come up here man if
you come up here with me I might says
yeah yeah I'm gonna be with you now
and he'd [ __ ] get loaded
and scope out chicks let's go about
chickens says oh man look at her oh like
he's Puerto Rican so yeah he's looking
at ass and [ __ ] you know he goes oh my
God
he did pretty well with women I thought
yeah oh yeah he could talk to women well
because like I said he was super funny
and he was like really charming and
stuff he was in Show Business yeah
if you guys don't think women won't make
out with with dwarves who are [ __ ]
crazy they had a damn
[ __ ] wrestling confident event they
had that a few times like I feel like
they did that manually for a while and
evidently it was a huge hit
it was a huge hit with the with the
ladies yeah the uh
most of those dwarves ended up with
their like faces embedded in [ __ ]
cleavage and brought it on [ __ ]
leaving with these girls you know
in their little [ __ ] wrestler outfits
see I told you I told you that a lot of
if you have like a good yeah personality
and you're funny and kind of outgoing
fun and stuff like that they're athletic
guys you know yeah
than women alike yeah you know what I
mean it's it's not a mystery not a
mystery funny
Zach says they're talking about
flashlights Zach said now I'm wondering
what a Fleshlight designed for a woman
would be what's like well we don't need
flashlights because we're we're on the
receiving end of that we are a
flashlight we're a living Fleshlight
[Laughter]
uh
um let's see Zach also says well she was
willing to put up with Stanley Kubrick's
[ __ ] yeah but I mean she wouldn't
have to like she wasn't married to
Stanley Kubrick though I mean I can
imagine how that was probably a pain in
the ass for however long it took to
shoot Eyes Wide Shut
but you knew that you could like go back
to your trailer at the end of the day
and be like that [ __ ] you
couldn't like you know what I mean if
you're like if you're married to Tom
Cruise you can't like get away from Tom
Cruise you know what I mean because
you're married to him so
you know what I mean Zach says I like to
think Tom Cruise is a good person deep
down he's just extremely deluded
yeah he only got into Scientology
because his first wife before Kidman got
him into it yeah I think that was Mimi
Rogers actually
whatever happened to her
I don't know
I already gave my theory I mean I'll
[ __ ] say it again if you guys want
you know it's a new new listeners can
hear it
um you know Jenny worked at a place
where it was it was a Scientology run
business and just having to do a crazy
Scientologist and I ran into some
scientologists one time when I was over
at Starbucks and I didn't know what I
was dealing with until later just how
these crazy [ __ ] it's like so
hard to explain if you haven't been
around them like all the time and it's
like imagine you have a bunch of idiots
that think they're [ __ ] smarter than
you
because I don't know
I don't know like how to deal with that
you know what I mean it's just kind of
like because there's nothing you can do
to like crack through their facade
because they're so deluded that it's
kind of like a LARPing situation when
they grow up in it so they don't know
any better and they can't fit in with
their regular world really
but yeah because some of them were
raised in it and like some of the people
that I worked with
um had grown up in it like they didn't
know anything they didn't know hardly
anything about the outside world like at
all the ones I ran into were not public
scientologists they were I think they
were from um flag base they were the uh
the people the office people
yeah that's what I think they were
I don't think they were I don't think
they were they weren't wearing uniforms
I don't think they were sea org I think
they were I think they're called staff
right yeah staff
and they have
um they were probably from Big Blue
yeah like what's the name of that what's
in that town Clearwater Clearwater
they're probably yeah that's where I
lived yeah and that's where that's where
the company I worked because they were
right outside I-4 they're at I-4 and 434
that at that at that um
so they must have been going south
headed south to go to flag or you know
not big blue it's the big Blues in
California in it no it's in Clearwater
it's in Clearwater okay pretty sure
isn't it no that's that's one in
California that's the hospital that they
painted blue oh okay yeah I forgot it's
not that one that's near Hollywood it's
uh I think it's called flag base
yeah it's called yeah because Clearwater
is kind of their main Hub they have hubs
everywhere but Clearwater is kind of
their main one
so I'm pretty sure that's where they
were going
that's the thing because I I mean when I
first moved over there I lived in Tampa
but and I had a job in Tampa but then I
got the job with that place and it paid
more so even though it was a farther
drive because I had to drive over the
bridge because I don't know if you like
Tampa it's kind of on the mainland but
then Clearwater and Saint Pete are like
on this little
thing it's not an island but it's kind
of like it's still attached to the
mainland but there's like a big lake
Inlet and so there's like a big Long
Causeway that you have to drive across
like all this water and so uh I started
driving over there and then I was like
well they're kind of weirdos but at
least like the pay is okay and then I
was like maybe I should move closer
because I got sick of like driving back
and forth because it was like 20 miles
and uh yeah so then I got an apartment
closer to the place and then I worked
there for about eight months and I was
like I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here or
I'm going to kill someone or myself
because I just couldn't [ __ ] deal
with it anymore I said being around
people like that and not everybody that
worked there was scientologists there
were some normal people there
um so that probably saved my sanity
somewhat but it got to a point where it
was like you couldn't even because clear
water is so Scientology
focused that even when I wasn't at work
like around scientologists I got to a
thing where you know I'd just be in the
grocery store and being like I bet
they're a Scientologist are they
scientologists too I'm just like I got
like paranoid and I was like I don't
want to live like this you know what I
mean like thinking that all the time
because then there's all these
Scientology Splinter groups
which are Scientology but it's cheaper
and it's from it's made from
ex-scientologists
remember that yeah I went to [ __ ] I
don't think you're with me didn't Marty
Rathbun do one of those yeah
but they'll change it up a little bit
and it'll be another version of
Scientology they have that out there too
people that leave Scientology try to
give a cheaper alternative murder Hornet
said squirrels yeah yeah squirrels
they're squirrel in the text squirrel in
the tech so um that's another thing I
couldn't say I'm like why are you guys
like making up phrases for stuff that
already has
I don't know it just seemed really dumb
like all of the stuff that I had that I
had to read like all of L Ron Hubbard
stuff and all of their like creepy like
corporate speak kind of stuff and it's
just like I was like you know that
there's a phrase for that already right
like why do you have to make up your own
silly little phrase for something that
already has like uh you know an
acknowledged phrase that that means it's
a fascinating cult
um
it's
it it's basically a UFO cult basically
that has
Inquisition on an inquisition and
Exorcism of alien Souls
demonic Souls that have attached to you
and the Inquisition is done on
a lie detector
um overall it's kind of like uh
the basic from framework of the religion
is the old Anton LaVey make a
[ __ ] a wizard model
where if you pay me enough money you can
level up until you're a wizard and then
your wizard level five and wizard level
six and each level you got to pay more
money and
you never really get the magical powers
do they're doing the same thing
um it's a very corporate
because
L Ron Hubbard
he he was not an idiot
he knew how to sell things and to kind
of
put on a con job to a certain extent
it's it's a mixture of the of the Navy
which he was a naval Commander he had he
was a commander of like some kind of
anti-submarine vessel for a little while
he didn't really do anything important
though
commanded that vessel it's a mixture of
the Navy and and a corporation
and a religion
and making a [ __ ] a wizard
but in this case they're making you
they're basically they're making you a
Jedi
and basically what they're doing yeah
and uh this is before Star Wars mostly
they're just emptying here mostly empty
in your pocket
believed it
I think he believed it
over time
because they said he died doing is
talking to alien souls and he
bullshitted himself [ __ ] is so hard
that it just came back and slapped his
own self in the face
he probably didn't believe it at first
but like I said honestly the best con
men are the ones that believe their own
[ __ ] because they're able to get
because it comes across as genuine
because they're actually delusional I
believe their own [ __ ] no
um granther said who would you rather
have as a neighbor a Scientologist or a
Mormon a Mormon I'm gonna go with more
Mormon also I mean scientologists I mean
Mormons are kind of obnoxious but
scientologists are like Superstars
Mormons I've dealt with were stand-up
people you could trust them to depend on
I've only known one or two Mormons in my
whole entire life and they seemed
futurous they seemed lovely um actually
the two that I've known it's like you
probably wouldn't even know they were
Mormon yeah like unless you specifically
asked about it they didn't like get all
up in your face about it scientologists
talking to scientologists particularly
people that grew up in it you can tell
there's something wrong with them like
immediately even if they don't tell you
they're a Scientologist you're like I
don't like that person is that you've
grown up in an alternate mind space
uh which
really skews your view of reality
because they believe in a lot of things
they're absolutely not true but they but
they believe that they're true
but
now some people say well there's a lot
of religions where people believe in
Scientology is different
all right I mean it's the same but it's
also different if that makes any sense
it's a lot more invasive it's a lot more
totalitarian
um and it's it has a lot of elements of
totalitarian communism in it in a way
or uh
what's his name
Jim Jones cult almost where
if you are not obeying then
you gotta you gotta be shunned you know
what I mean well that's what I said I
think that's why it's kind of classified
more as a cultism because like you know
Christianity and stuff as much as I'm
not a big fan of religion in general
um Christianity and stuff like that
people can come and go as they please uh
they don't charge you fifty thousand
dollars for like you know you can just
go get a Bible somewhere and read it and
like say hey I'm a Christian everyone's
like okay fine whatever like No One's
Gonna care about it really but I mean
Scientology has this whole you have to
do this exactly like this and you have
to do things the way we want them and
it's like you have to do things in this
very very structured kind of way and if
you do it wrong then you get in trouble
and then we're gonna put you know what I
mean it's just like very very very yeah
but I I am correct Marxism can also in
certain elements of Marxism can also be
classified as a faith uh is it it's a
very faith-like
um system or or a very faith-like
um
uh collection of almost like
holy scriptures the books that that are
being written and it's
Karl Marx's very L Ron hubbardish it's
just uh
the Topic's a little bit different but
there's a lot a lot of there's a lot of
crossover especially when you start
getting into Frankfurt School stuff
it it it is pretending to be science but
it is not it's not even social science
it's faith
it's just written in a scholarly fashion
because the guys that wrote it had
Marxist materials have a high verbal IQ
and they have a fairly good education so
they can fake a scholarly work
um even though it doesn't make any sense
when you actually it's philosophy and
philosophy is only as a step away from
religion anyway that's that's all it is
you got to be careful of philosophy
because it's a type of religion so in
politics politics is a type of
philosophy so it's all kind of in that
same what do you call it Spectrum you
gotta be real careful belief
what is what it is
belief can bite you in the ass
because the human mind is not real good
filtering out [ __ ] reality from
[ __ ] you can believe in some
[ __ ] just a hundred percent and it's
not true
they got people that think that you can
fly if you have enough faith
and he'll jump off buildings
they didn't fly
spoilers they splashed
like that well it takes them out of the
gene pool yeah Danny rolling said Wiccan
sounds like the best religion uh just
because it's all nature and [ __ ]
honestly I always thought that too if I
was going to be of any religion which
I'm not because it's not my thing but
yeah Wicked just seems very chill it's
Hocus Pocus though well yeah I'm not
saying that but it's just kind of like
they're not hurting anybody though yeah
you know what I mean if they want to
believe that they can stand around a
circle with crystals and chant and stuff
and that'll like bring them it's just
like whatever fine it's not it's not
hurting anybody but yeah it's very old
though either I think no it's not I
think it's 1960s yeah I mean I yeah I
kind of like the roots of it are a
little bit uh older than that but not
yeah it's not like the ancient yeah they
they do take Traditions from like much
older stuff but Wicca as you understand
it nowadays is mostly like a 60s thing
yeah and you can write a Wicca book and
it'd be this year and it would be
accepted
I remember when the uh Harry krishnas
used to be in the Atlanta airport and at
the rest stop the Georgia Florida rest
stop yeah on I-75 yeah I remember them
but you don't really see them anymore
but I remember that being like a big
thing
they were getting busted um a lot of
people don't don't realize that
the main the main objective for the
Harry Krishna was to pick up young
good-looking girls and guys that that's
all it was
they were looking for young good-looking
people so they could take back ahead to
their little [ __ ] compound and have
sex with them that's that's what it was
like a sex girl their Christian weren't
they weren't honest and it was
constantly changing members I saw a
whole [ __ ] report on him
they were more like sexual predators
yeah murder Horner points out that uh
lrh modeled Scientology after the temple
at Golden Dawn yep yeah yeah there was a
lot of that yeah I thought we talked
about that some on like kind of some of
the Scientology shows and I think the
show we did about Jack Parsons that was
in the Aleister Crowley show and stuff
so make a [ __ ] a wizard um
business model
you can make a lot of money making a
[ __ ] into a wizard
you got to do this you want to be a
wizard
I mean if I thought that it was possible
to become a wizard I would want to
become a wizard too but it's not
possible so I'm just not gonna bother
make a [ __ ] Jedi
it'd be neat if you could but yeah you
can't yeah
there's a lot of Genius in certain ways
in Scientology you know what I mean it's
there's a lot of books that you have to
read uh it's gobbledygook uh you kind of
if you're a Scientologist you want to
believe it
it has a very corporate image on the
outside of it so therefore it must be
true
which is something that from
Hubbard's day
that was a good sales tactic because it
was at the end of World War II
at the beginnings of the [ __ ] merger
of the [ __ ] military industrial
complex where
the military
and the government started to have a
more of a corporate appearance because
it all kind of merged together
and it followed that religion should
start having a corporate appearance that
it would in those days with those
Generations if something looked
corporate and official you could trust
it
so that was a very good tactic to to go
for the for a
corporate religion
yeah
it grew people liked it meanwhile it
just creeped me out even more yeah
because I hate all that corporate [ __ ]
it's a corporate religion now here
here's all of the jargon they come up
with and stuff like that it's just oh my
God it gives me a migraine all of that
crap uh Dave says Hey gotta go I hope to
see you both there love you we love you
we'll probably go yeah I don't know when
we're gonna get there but we'll get
there now the thing about
hovered
um
contrary to what maybe what you might
think you know what I was what I've said
about scientology so far I'm not
anti-hubbard
um I'm trying to look at Hubbard from a
realistic
viewpoint
the cult lights Hubbard and he was a
good leader to them
um they had a lot of fun Nostalgia for
Hubbard
um in the old days of the cult Hubbard
[ __ ]
was evidently much loved and he didn't
he didn't sexually abuse people which
that's very weird that yeah I think he's
maybe the only cult leader that didn't
do that which is and he was surrounded
by a cute young cabin girls who were
like his secretaries and stuff and he
evidently never
according to those girls they said that
no he he kept his hands to himself and
everybody he was very respectful and he
would sit out there on the free winds
and tell all these stories and they
would about what was happening on other
planets and alien souls and [ __ ] and
they'd be out there all enraptured at
his his [ __ ] you know he he he's
channeling it he's he's like the Messiah
he's the source of all the that's the
way they believe you know so he's
channeling it all
uh so in some ways
Hubbard had good character
um in in a certain way in in many ways
he he was not abusing his power usually
the Hallmark of a cult is that you you
abuse your power to get money and sex
well yeah that's kind of the reason why
most of them are formed yeah L Ron
Hubbard was just he was after money
crazy but he wasn't he wasn't getting
the sex
um he he evidently respected P respected
women uh in that way
uh try to think of another thing that
made him different is um
I think he actually believed a lot of
what he was saying
and I also think he thought the
technology and that's what he called the
spiritual technology I think he thought
it was a was an experimental work in
progress
and that it was something that he could
slowly
bring into existence uh through
experimentation
uh I think he thought it was working uh
but I also think that uh he knew he
could make money with it so it was kind
of a
but they would have thought that that
was a good thing that you had to have
you had to make money in order to get
the cult to expand
to save the Earth
were they saving the Earth no
no you weren't going to clear the planet
that's what they call it and make
everybody a clear you were going to
clear the the planet at the price of
Scientology was asking for yeah who the
[ __ ] afford that you had to have
thirty thousand dollars per person to
clear to clear the planet nobody was
going to spend that kind of money well
some people will but it's only if they
have that to piss away though yeah it
was it was a rich white person's
religion yeah big deal what
um yeah murder Hornet said do the
Hubbard lips Tom
wow we have to know that on Stick them
where you get him
like that approxima Centauri
because he would have mispronounced some
[ __ ] we had a bunch of aliens called the
Freebirds and the Freebirds had their
own spaceships they looked kind of like
DC nines yeah
[Laughter]
you don't have big enough lips for that
his lips looked like
I don't know they were very anus like
foreign
even though Louie just said uh lrh isn't
dead he's doing research on another
planet yeah well you know well he can he
dropped his body he can just come back
to this planet and get me if he's mad
I'm just saying come on Ella rage
Glenn little said oh yeah he kept his
hands to himself wasn't he a compulsive
masturbator then again who isn't maybe
he was I never heard that maybe he was I
haven't heard it either
um no shame like I said they're not
hurting anybody the only thing
character-wise I could say that he that
was kind of negative that was negative
about lrh is that he wasn't a very good
family man
um he'd [ __ ] over wives and children but
his wives and children he if he did like
one he had a son he didn't really
approve of because he was evidently gay
he [ __ ] that one over
um
he just
he wasn't real he didn't have strong
emotional connections with
wives and family members
that's the only thing I could say well
the [ __ ] that he was doing was just too
important man it was too important
although like I said I've read a lot of
lrh's stuff because I had to like for
work and stuff like that dude was
clearly delusional I mean I'm not even
the psychiatrist and I'm pretty
confident saying that I mean he really
has some issues
he really had some issues like some of
the [ __ ] that he wrote I was just kind
of like well all right I like to put it
right inside the cult leader Spectrum
when you put him
inside the spectrum of cult leaders he's
way above Jim Jones all right a lot
better than that
I'd say he's just right underneath hung
song Moon
Reverend Moon
I Ain't Met Reverend moons a little bit
better
we still haven't done a show about the
Moonies I keep putting it's like it's on
my list still and I keep putting it in
the poll every now and then but we never
do we never did yeah do it that's
actually like a really interesting the
thing about L Ron Hubbard is that you
know he just started the [ __ ] like to
make money more or less and he did seem
to be kind of to an extent like a True
Believer I think he believed it more
like as time went on
but I think I don't know I don't know
how much you can hold him responsible
for like what happened after he died
because I would argue I mean Scientology
is easily one of the best
powerful Cults it was I don't think it
is anymore not anymore but I mean just
to the extent because most Cults are
very very small and very localized and
it's like they don't have the same kind
of power and money and influence that
Scientology had and still has to a
lesser degree Scientology was the only
organization
that ever significantly in a large
number penetrated the FBI and parts of
the federal government it's called
operation of Snow White
that's a wild [ __ ] yeah that's what I
mean and they got away with it only only
lrh's wife went to prison he's like yeah
look her she's responsible he didn't go
he didn't go to prison hide it he made
her do his jail time I tell you what you
pulled some [ __ ] like that off yeah
smother you in your [ __ ] sleep made
her do a tail top
and what was funny is that he penetrated
the FBI because he he he was convinced
that the FBI was coming after him and
the church like they weren't before but
now they are so he had he had all these
church members become FBI employees and
worked their way in into the into the a
lot and there was a lot of them and they
were in there as FBI and scientologists
and it was just to know he just wanted
to know what the FBI knew about him and
it turned out nothing yep he did it for
nothing the FBI had no interest in
Scientology that's what I'm saying it's
like like I said and now they do good
job dumbass
probably should have just like kept your
nose clean like kept to yourself and
nobody would have even yeah but the
thing is real important well yeah the
thing about it like I said if you read
his writings to any great extent like
he's very delusional and a lot of times
like with that delusion comes paranoia
like and you think like you're a lot
more important than you are and like a
lot of people care what you're doing but
the only reason they started carrying
what he was doing because he pulled that
[ __ ] it was like oh well obviously now
we have to watch you because Jesus
Christ yeah but before that they didn't
give a crap about about them they
weren't doing anything in particular
there's it's funny because it's a it's a
it's a large wealthy
cult
that has a corporate
look to it that owns a lot of expensive
properties
it looks from the outsides like
something very successful something that
would have a lot of secret knowledge and
would be like real high tech you know
but it's really much to do about nothing
really
it's illusion
and what the church is kind of
evolved into is kind of like a real
estate scam it's more like a just
something that holds a bunch of Real
Estate
it's weird it wasn't was supposed to be
that way it's not what they were trying
to do
but they can't hoard money because
they're supposed to be a charity so they
have to keep buying things
so they keep buying properties and
turning them into uh basically
bookstores religious bookstores
but they don't sell any books
but they put people in there and have
people pulling duty at a religious
bookstore that just sells one book over
and over again
crazy crazy when you think about it it's
like something they're like potemkin
cities out of some communist country
so I was saying there's a lot of
elements of like a communist
totalitarian
quality to it kind of like something you
see out in out of North Korea where it's
all artificial you know like an
artificial store
an artificial religious bookstore
seven one book over and over and over
and over again with [ __ ] TVs blaring
and you know the same video and it's
totally fake they don't intend to sell
any books out of that
because those books don't sell
that was just [ __ ] man Louie said uh
wasn't lrh on psychiatric drugs when he
dropped his body
uh I don't think they dropped his body
whoops no no that didn't take me they
did not believe in Psychiatry or
psychology at all well that doesn't mean
that he wasn't on the show no he wasn't
um he was on other drugs though
um but if I remember correctly
the Scientology was uh supposed to be in
it an answer to Psychiatry and
psychology
that it supplants it
and it so
they weren't allowed any of that kind of
[ __ ] I think
um
if I remember correctly he was not in
good mental health I forgot what it was
he was taking
but they didn't take any kind of uh
psychoactive Pharmaceuticals
from what I remember they weren't
allowed any of those
but I think
like it wouldn't surprise me if L Ron
Hubbard took LSD or something you know
or
but I'd have to go back and look I know
he was kind of out of his mind in the
final years and that was that was during
the time that
David miscavige started to who was kind
of like a
a top flunky of the church
this position himself for a Total
Takeover and he took over the church did
it by eliminating a bunch of people
he eliminated him by
accusing them of [ __ ] stealing money
and accusing them of uh being somehow
linked to the death of L Ron Hubbard and
he was able to get rid of a bunch of
people that were above him through that
then he ended up being head of the
church c.o.b chairman of the board
crafter said doesn't uh Reverend Moon's
son have some AR-15 cult in Arizona
called gun church I don't know I've
heard of that but I didn't know that if
it was uh rubber Moon Sun though we
should probably look that up we'll look
into it moon was cool uh in a weird way
he was Christian but like a
a a
paranormal Christian kind of like if a
Christian was a Jedi
in the spirit spiritualism he uh said
that he had they were they were real uh
right wing
uh anti-communist
and uh at one time Moon said that he
left his body and actually projected in
in the astral world did did the things
that had to be done to cause the
collapse of the Soviet Union he caused
collapse of the Soviet Union and
communism
that's quite a claim
but that's the kind of badass [ __ ] that
occult leader should claim
if you have a huge cult and the Moonies
had a huge cult a lot of money
and a lot of nice buildings and
everything you know they they're not a
two-bit organization it looked like
[ __ ] mansions and every you know you
know the nice buildings and they were in
Korea and in the United States and uh
they might be in a couple of other
countries I don't know
the only thing that I've heard that was
bad about the Moonies is they do
disconnection
and this connection is not pretty much
all cults do that to a degree that's one
of the re that's one of the ways that
you know that it's a cult when they
discourage you from any outside
information or discourage you from like
uh talking to talking to relatives that
laugh relatives that laughed and stuff
like that yeah that's a red flag right
there disconnection and
disconnection is huge in because they're
trying to isolate you that's why so that
you only get a steady stream of [ __ ]
yeah that you don't have any outside
perspectives I think disconnection is
one of scientology's huge
um or one of their main problems
if they were to get rid of disconnection
they'd probably be better off
but Scientology can't make any changes
that's a problem
lrh told gave Commandments and told them
to do certain things they don't have the
authority to change it
like all the bases talk to each other
through Telex
because that's what lrh told them to use
Telex Telex is [ __ ] 60 years old
net 60 or yeah 50 might be older might
be older is it I don't even know how do
they even get that [ __ ] anymore do they
have to like make their own Telex if you
guys know what a Telex is
it's like a printer that you put a
telephone an old dial up well it's like
a fax machine like a fax machine and
they can send a [ __ ] message to you
and it would come through the [ __ ]
phone and it would print it out on the
other end it's like a Proto fax machine
like a Proto fax machine
uh parsaval cheers from Germany well hey
what's up uh I'm so drunk tonight he
says go ahead I'll shave my head smooth
with foam and razor if a woman comes in
and wins three rounds of rock paper
scissors against me challenge [ __ ]
shaving your head shave your balls man
well you could why not balls [ __ ] you
can shave your head as [ __ ] put them put
it put put take a take a ride I would
not advise [ __ ] drop them [ __ ]
balls and balls while you're drunk
don't give them any ideas
thank you very much Camp guy
happy Friday everybody says
Camp guy said I'm watching the new
Hell's Kitchen with the waifu back in a
few minutes ooh is the new Hell's
Kitchen on oh I just watched the new
season of MasterChef I finished that one
I think I told you I was like I'm not
gonna spoil it in case you haven't
watched it but I was very very happy
with who won I was I was rooting for
this person
uh yeah Zach says ever since I learned
my ancestors from Norway were lutherans
I'm kind of interested in joining a
Lutheran Church and grow up there said
lutherans are like Catholic light all
the platitudes minus the pope yeah I
kind of feel like if you're gonna it's
in Marilyn Manson or somebody say
something like that that like Lutheran
if you have to be like a Christian
that's kind of the best one because you
have like all the cool [ __ ] about
Catholicism without all the [ __ ] didn't
Dr Price say that maybe I don't remember
I don't know I don't know enough about
it we've had him on as a guest of the
show Dr Price and he's
a mythicist he doesn't believe any of
that happened but he goes to church for
the for the experience just the the
singing and the songs and the
you know but he doesn't like happy
clappers and I think it might have been
a Lutheran Lutheran is what where it's
it's there is no real sermon
it's a bunch of singing and ritual
and you're in and you do your thing you
have your religious experience then you
leave
I think it might have been Lutheran I
mean the thing about me it's like yeah
look I'm like the biggest atheist that
ever atheisted but still I really like
the whole Gestalt of like Catholic
churches and it's like I love stained
glass windows I love all that medieval
religious art I love all that kind of
stuff make no mistake
when you go through the the scripture
the early scriptures and you understand
them you understand how the church
worked that's what Christianity was
Christianity was not about what was in
the Bible it was the experience of going
it was kind of like the theater of the
day
and it was to have a religious
experience
that was what it originally was all
about
Danny really said shave your eyebrows
off and Sharpie them on that's what I do
um better than plucking them uh we like
to see Gordon yelling and everyone yeah
I like see Gordon yelling and everyone
too although honestly I like I found and
maybe this is just kind of like me as
I've gotten older because I love Gordon
Ramsay and I love like all his shows and
stuff but I tend to prefer the ones
where he's I mean don't get me wrong I
do like when he yells at like people on
the show that I don't like or that think
that I think need yelling at but I think
he's better when he's actually like nice
to people you know what I mean because
he is he seems like a nice person he
just kind of got this reputation of
being like really shouty and everything
like that because he is but
I mean when he's really like nice to
people and really mentoring people and
stuff like that he's actually seems like
a really nice dude you know what I mean
and he seems like a very genuine dude
and to be honest Gordon Ramsay I don't
know like hey Gord Ramsay like if you're
out there if you're listening call me
because how the [ __ ] when the [ __ ] does
a dude sleep when does he sleep
he has a million shows yeah all the time
like I was looking he has shows that I
don't even know that he made
I'm like when the [ __ ] do you have time
to do all of this [ __ ] and run all the
restaurants that he runs and he writes
cookbooks and it's like yeah I know he's
probably he's like zillionaire and he
has like a staff and [ __ ] like that but
God damn like when the [ __ ] I mean on
the TV shows he has to be there to be on
the show yeah and that's not you know
what I mean and that's like a long
commitment because I think like Master
Chef and all that kind of stuff that's
like over several that's a month or it's
a long time that where they shoot that
it actually might be longer than that so
it's like I don't I don't understand
like where he has he must have like that
[ __ ] time Turner thing that Hermione
had in the Harry Potter do you want to
try some of that orange
um
whiskey next oh that's right I forgot
yeah
yeah we got is it um wait it's not Jack
Daniels it's Jim Beam yeah beam orange
yeah like we had got the Jim Beam Apple
before which I really like and then uh
but he went to the uh liquor store the
other day and said oh they had the
orange and I saw that in the liquor
store the other day and I was like oh
that'd probably be pretty good so we're
gonna try that out later on but I just
like I haven't finished my peach vodka
yet though well I'll just do mine first
okay and you can get some I guess we'll
have it on the rocks
I mean what could well I guess you could
mix it with you seriously I don't have
any Coca-Cola that's what you're
supposed to mix it with oh yeah I guess
whiskey and Coke what do we have we have
root beer that would be terrible that
would be that would be yucky
and I have Diet
Cherry Coke but that would be terrible
that would all say for you no the way to
go it's just on the rocks
we'll see how it goes but like I said
I want to know what it tastes like yeah
on its own
and then you know like what you can mix
it with later because the Jim Beam Apple
was great on the rocks that was very
good just on its own yeah
and if you guys don't know what we're
talking about Europeans got parcel ball
on there
Jim Beam is like traditionally kind of
like
very standard kind of
Tennessee whiskey or might be Kentucky
minute whiskey it's Southern whiskey
it's fried yeah
it's really wasn't that good it's not
bad it's not great it's not bad it's not
great now they're starting to flavor it
they kind of elevating it
you can get real good Jim Beam you know
that's been aged in barrels and but you
got to pay a lot more for it well they
have them at different prices they have
a different price which is nice yeah
right but this one is kind of like
they're uh just a 20 bottle
Jim Beam Orange
and it's something you mix
or you can just drink it on the Rocks
like a sipping whiskey we're gonna see
what it tastes like that the green apple
was good
yeah I liked that a lot
I liked that a lot yeah Zach said uh
lutherans are allowing uh gay clergy now
which is interesting if I could I join a
black church because those look fun
you can nobody's stopping you
uh Sly says uh love your red hair Jenny
thank you very much uh let's see Zach
also says by the way I have an upcoming
horror movie you'll like bones and all
same director as the Suspiria remake
imagine Bonnie and Clyde in the 80s and
their cannibals see that sounds like
something
that I might need to investigate because
that sounds like that sounds pretty
[ __ ] awesome that sounds pretty
[ __ ] awesome
uh Oscar says Chef Emeril is a far
superior Chef to Gordon Ramsay I mean
that's neither here nor there I've been
to neither one of their restaurants so I
don't even know what their cooking is
like but personality wise I don't know
Emeril Lagasse gets on my [ __ ] nerves
I don't know why that is not he doesn't
get on my nerves as much as Guy Fieri
Fieri uh you know what I mean but I
don't know Gordon Ramsay he just seems
like I could hang with with Gordon
Ramsay but Emeril Lagasse I don't think
I could hang that's what we're that's
what we're gonna go ahead and do
we're gonna go ahead and do that
oh smell
very orangey almost smells like Drambuie
it does
Glenn little said I shaved my balls so
many times it looks like a hippie's
tobacco pouch now
[Laughter]
is that too much information there's no
such thing on this show no such thing
let's see how is it Tom how is it
yes no
what is that face portend
he's thinking about it
he's really contemplating this you guys
well it has some spice to it well yeah I
mean what is this clove it's probably
clove cinnamon okay
that makes sense
it also has um
you trap all right I think it's good
oh I like that yeah
I like that
it's very strong so I'm not really sure
how much but it's I like it because it's
like it has a little bit of a whiskey
flavor to it but it's very very orangey
yeah orange and um and some heat it's
got a little bit a little bit I think
it's cinnamon heat but not so much that
it's gonna give me heartburn I'm not
gonna have in that reaction so and um
vanilla maybe thank you Jeffy art
today I purchased six brands of pumpkin
beer at Total Wine oh yeah yeah okay
Dogfish Head and harpoon's Dunkin Donuts
pumpkin I will gladly give you my
thoughts over the next few weeks yes
please do because I'm man I'm into the
pumpkin spice [ __ ] man seriously
actually the best one was that uh
pumpkin spice uh malt beverage
yeah that was actually the best it was a
latte right it's a latte well no like
the one I got one at Publix like we got
a couple at the liquor store and then I
was at Publix and I got one that was
essentially like a pumpkin spice latte
but with booze in it yeah so it wasn't
even beer it was like a malt beverage
and that [ __ ] was good because it
actually tasted like uh pumpkin spice
latte yeah except boozy yeah yeah and it
um
it wasn't even trying to it wasn't even
trying to be a beer
yeah it was just pumpkin spice
pumpkin spice latte happened to be
alcoholic could have been vodka in it
for all you knew didn't matter well it
was a it was billed as a hard coffee
yeah it didn't have much of an alcohol
flavor but you could probably slam those
and get [ __ ] trash like I got slammed
off them damn Mojitos I told you I
haven't seen you that drunk in a while
yeah
Jeff yard said hurry and get Dogfish
Head a lot of places are almost out yeah
I kind of figured that when pumpkin
spice season comes on everybody is like
oh it's fall and they kind of do what I
do and it's like I want all the pumpkin
spice all the things
I want all that Oscar says Jenny how
about reviewing the four VHS Anthology
movies leading up to VHS 99 later this
month on shutter yeah that's actually a
good idea I might actually uh get into
doing that what I'm gonna do tomorrow
the video that I'm putting up tomorrow
it's written but I haven't like I got to
record it and edit it like tomorrow
morning
is somebody told me remember how I did
the show about masters of horror like
the you know from 2000 when was that
2007 2008 the mcgaris show
um DJ Maniac told me you know uh there
was actually a third season of that like
a third unofficial season except it was
called something else and it was on NBC
and so I was like holy [ __ ] I totally
forgot about that and that whole series
is on YouTube and Voodoo and stuff like
that now so I did a whole review of that
so it's kind of like masters of horror
but on network TV it was actually it was
not bad actually
I think I'd only seen one episode of it
because I was watching one of them and I
was like oh I kind of remember this but
the rest of them I didn't remember so I
must have only seen it
okay so grandpa said just a heads up
after three years of retirement granther
has accepted a full-time job offer and
will have to give up watching YouTube
and Reddit all the time so my time here
will be limited off we will miss you but
hopefully you can drop by and
talk and talk to us sometimes okay Jim
Beam Orange
it's not bad it's good I like it
um I I kind of prefer
the Apple I like the Apple better too
but that's actually good I like that
it's very I mean the Orange is very very
strong and I like that about it
they have two other flavors one of
them's honey and the other one is some
kind of I think it's called fire or
cinnamon or something
the cinnamon is kind of like uh it's got
like Fireball but not quite as sweet
and I'd like to try the honey
I've had the Jack Daniels honey and
that's very good well I I think it's Jim
Beam Honey though there is a Jim Beam
honeymoon okay yeah but I've had the
Jack Daniels honey yeah and that's
actually very good so I imagine the gym
beam is probably good too
uh grafter says Total Wine rocks
uh
uh it's the size of a cold but filled
with booze well the ABC Liquor we have
by our house is kind of like that too
it's pretty big
Zach said uh bones and all it was what
we were talking to the movie we were
talking about before the trailer had a
Leonard Cohen song in it which song
because I love Leonard Cohen he said
that sent me down a rabbit hole of his
music I now have like three of his songs
stuck in my head so annoying but so good
yeah I mean I love Leonard Cohen so I
don't know what like what song was in
the trailer but let me know okay people
I shaved off the [ __ ] the beard side
it's uh it's shaved it's just this now
just the [ __ ] evil Spock just evil
Spock beard that's how I'm gonna go
it's easier it's doing this when I kept
looking at it in the mirror straight in
because I had it cut kind of thin
there wasn't a lot of coverage there
so I just I was like you know what [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] side [ __ ] it doesn't
make a big difference it's I I still got
good jaw action
good job action I think I still got a
good job all right action huh yeah okay
well like I said I didn't you know it
hadn't grown out to an extent that you
could really see it all that way yeah it
was just it wasn't going to get much
better okay it wasn't gonna get much
better
Zach says you want it darker from his
last album what his voice was at its
graveliest
and it was pretty Gravelly to start with
granther said some call that beard a man
[ __ ]
that's [ __ ] funny I can see that I
can see that I mean [ __ ] ass
[ __ ]
well he didn't make it up that's a real
thing he's just he's just telling you
he's just imparting information
when you just have the [ __ ] Ming the
merciless out uh [ __ ] version it's a
lot easier you know what I mean because
it's smaller you can get the angles
correct
you know
hairs it's a smaller it's a smaller
facial hair apparatus
a facial hair ever yeah
hair is complicated I really really wish
like I've told you before I really
really see linwood's in there slices
Tom's evil Spock yeah it's like evil
Spock he was [ __ ] yeah so it's gonna be
like we're not gonna be able to tell you
apart from like the evil Spock is this
me Tommy was Spock yes you he says evil
spook
he said oh he was spooked I can't see it
on my glasses on well maybe you should
get your glasses I don't know he
I don't believe you're evil spook man
[ __ ] stop stop calling yourself
that'll be all right
Danny Rowley says out of all eight of
the potential zodiac Killers named who
do you think is possibly the killer out
of them I don't even know who the eight
are I remember I don't remember them
either they evidently had something new
with some DNA came out yeah I heard that
sounds pretty plausible
maybe we should do a zodiac we could do
it we can do it yeah I'm gonna rant that
down because we'll we'll do an update on
zodiac
yeah
whole zodiac he's a classic
and you know I would say well they'll
never catch that guy but I kind of well
he's probably dead now I never thought
they'd catch [ __ ] um
what uh original Night Stalker yeah
Golden State killer Golden State kill
same dude if you all haven't been
listening to the program long
we did a thing on Golden State killer
also known as the original Night Stalker
now I profiled that [ __ ] before
they got it and before they caught him
and I got it right
I got it right I profiled the [ __ ]
because I was trying to put myself in
his shoes what kind of dude's doing this
I knew he was a cop
he was a cop
and it turns out he was a cop he was an
active duty cop and he was doing that at
least part of it
that's all
he was a [ __ ]
that was a perfect storm there
uh bad [ __ ] and then the skills
to get it done
and then the hatred
these are free yeah and the thing about
like when they caught him like he was
like you could tell just by looking at
him that he was just like a [ __ ]
horrible old man rage monster yeah
he uh he was mad that he was a little
dick [ __ ]
that's what I believe
the truth is always in the gutter it's
something real simple and low because
the the surviving women would one of the
main
descriptions was is that he was a little
dick he was a little dick dude which
he's trying to overcompensate and he's
[ __ ] hating on these women well I
kind of feel like that's a lot of yeah
yeah that's a lot of the serial killer
kind of thing unless they're completely
just psychotic and crazy and just have
like this motives then they're usually
they have some kind of deep-seated issue
that they're like overcompensating for
right and he's definitely one of those
that was like overcompensating for lack
of perceived masculinity yeah but the
thing about it is that if you have like
a time if you have like a micro there's
a lot of dudes are like that well if you
have a micro dick right yeah one it's
like there's a lot of dudes like that
and they don't become serial killers
because you should like you know there's
other things you can do like you don't
have to become a serial killer obviously
but I do I don't know I kind of feel
like if you have a micro dick you know
um Pro tip don't go raping people
because that's the first thing they're
gonna report yeah he has a tiny ass
penis yeah so therefore that's why he's
doing it yeah so which makes you look
even worse which makes you look even
worse right
are they not thinking that far yeah I
guess no I guess not
and uh
if that's what you're working with you
better learn how to [ __ ] offer some
other [ __ ] to a woman yeah that's what
I'm saying yeah there's ways to get
around [ __ ] like there's ways to get
around pretty much everything I mean
unless you're just a [ __ ] human being
that that was a problem within him yeah
exactly exactly I'm sure like had he
been a cool [ __ ] it wouldn't
matter it wouldn't have mattered like
the women that were like pissed off
about it probably weren't hanging out
worth hanging out with anyways yeah you
know what I mean like if he could do
other [ __ ]
dudes are getting bent out of shape
oversized Queens they got some women out
there that that's all they're gonna go
for but they tend to be younger women
who outgrow that phase
really what matters is kind of
[ __ ] putting putting [ __ ]
meat on the table can you hold the house
together can you trust him can he keep
his dick in his pants is he gonna
[ __ ] you know I mean well
yeah is he fun to be around is he
reliable is he fun to be around is he
kind of real is he gonna listen to you
when you talk is he gonna like there's a
lot of other things that are important
yeah and particularly if you're in a
relationship with somebody for a really
long time it's like you know dick size
and [ __ ] like that it gets less and less
important like as time goes on like you
said that's more of like a Young
Person's kind of yeah oh [ __ ] what's
his name
that was a problem he was having with
himself
I'm guarantee you yeah you know that was
a problem he was had with himself
[ __ ] he wasn't having problems with
women because of that he just that was
something he couldn't accept with
himself he and the thing about it too is
that sometimes I'm thinking about like I
think we talked about this and when we
did the show about like incels about
like Elliot Roger and [ __ ] like that
yeah a lot of times dudes like that
because they're so mired and self-hatred
they perceive it as everybody else
picking on them when a lot of times
people aren't even like aware of it or
not even thinking about them or
something like that the thing about like
people like Elliot Roger and stuff like
that they're just kind of like they kind
of think oh well I have a nice car and
I'm you know okay looking and stuff like
that so people should just like be
attracted to me like magically and I'm
like that's not how that works though
and like most people just don't even
know you're alive because most people
don't know other people are alive
generally you know what I mean unless
you draw attention to yourself it was
like it was like that Korean kid that
shot up the damn University
uh Kim Chung sole or some [ __ ] like that
he dressed up in the whole outfit and
gunned everybody down
um he was he made a video that's just
totally incoherent he think he's saying
you've you know basically you've mocked
me you've ridiculed me you defeated me
this and then I'm coming back with it
nobody even knew who that dude was well
that was oh that's what I'm saying like
Elliot Roger it was the whole thing like
I'm gonna make you all pay for what you
do I'm like nobody did anything no two
yeah nobody did anything to him and he
and nobody knew who he was that's what I
mean I think a lot of the problem is
that these dudes are like so delusional
that they think the whole entire world
revolves around so people are just like
living their regular lives without even
knowing you exist and somehow you're
doing it at them even though you don't
even know who that is like I could just
be walking down the [ __ ] Street one
day just going down to get a [ __ ]
coffee at Starbucks or whatever and this
[ __ ] is like sitting there going
that [ __ ] shouldn't even look at me or
you know or something like that I'm like
I didn't mean to [ __ ] notice you just
like I didn't notice these zillion other
people that I just [ __ ] walked by
because I'm just going to get a [ __ ]
coffee you know what I mean but it's
like in his mind it was like this big
huge deal and like everybody needed to
like feel his wrath or whatever because
nobody was paying attention enough
attention to and I'm just gonna I don't
understand that at all I don't
understand that at all it's like
most of the time 99.99 of the time
people just are not noticing you because
they got their own [ __ ] going on that's
just how life is you know what I mean
nobody
you're not owed anybody's attention like
that yeah especially people who don't
even know who the [ __ ] you are you're
just a random ass [ __ ] I don't
know you you know what I mean [ __ ]
uh grafter said just like some girls
like big dogs some dudes like chicks
with oversized labias
[Laughter]
oh titties and ass yeah well I'm just
saying that but no I know anything
that's kind of like yeah anything that's
kind of like physical like that it's
like yeah people have preferences and
stuff but it's just kind of about the
whole person like we've talked about
that before because it's like a lot of
times it's like even if you have like a
type oh I like you know guys that look
like this or I like girls that look like
this but then if you meet somebody that
doesn't look exactly like that but is
kind of like super cool in other ways
and you kind of live really to them in
other ways then you know then it doesn't
really matter as much
the way I look at it you know like um
beef curtains yeah beef
that's one of my favorite well actually
my favorite
um my favorite word for vagina is or
phrase for a vagina is Squish Mitten but
I don't remember where I first heard
that but I was like oh that's my
favorite but beef curtains is pretty
good too I consider myself to be a
pretty typical dude all right and you
guys in the comment section you guys can
[ __ ] [ __ ] because Sly is talking
about the measure of a man yeah I know
it's talking about [ __ ] it's more
about how Dependable you are that's
really what matters to a woman over time
especially outside a certain age group
but uh oh [ __ ] I forgot exactly what I
was gonna say
um
[ __ ] it doesn't matter I'm just going to
go back to this drinking
um whatever okay whatever the uh
yeah really I forgot what I was gonna
say uh well I remember what it was I
consider myself to be a pretty typical
guy guys in general like novelty
well that covers a lot of distance
if you see some chicks she's [ __ ]
very well and died maybe she's [ __ ]
big on the top she's big on the bottom
she's big on the top and she's so big on
about or she's real little on top little
on the bottom she's skinny there's a lot
of different ways to kind of like get a
guy's attention guys are not the average
guy is not real picky
as long as the a woman has a certain
amount of impact to her visual
[ __ ] uh uh [ __ ] stimuli you know
it isn't one in other words I'm like a
lot of other guys who I don't really
have one type there are many types
so really like the average guy it's not
real [ __ ] difficult to please really
you know I kind of feel like women
aren't either yeah no
I mean because it kind of it kind of
depends on the person yeah it kind of
depends on person like there are some
girls [ __ ] like Jenny Jenny knows
exactly what I'm talking there are some
girls that they're they're skinny all
right there's not much but they're still
cute yeah there are other girls that are
kind of a little heavy but they carry it
real well they're cute too it's just
you're not really
it's like Baskin Robbins
okay that's actually a good analogy yeah
there's 31 it's like they're all pretty
good they're all pretty good as long as
there's some style there I mean you have
a few favorites but all of them I mean
you're not gonna say no to like most of
them well it depends on the situation
there they got mud Ducks out there too
like nope no thanks you know what I mean
you're not you didn't have any teeth
nope you [ __ ] you don't shower you
know it's just there's a lot I mean
there's there's a lot of [ __ ] you know
some girls are homeless bag ladies for a
certain reason and dudes aren't going
for that so you know you have to look at
the other extremes too you know
but in there's a lot
there's a lot more ways to be attractive
than just one way there's a [ __ ] a
whole bunch of ways to be attractive
they got girls that are just fat but
they're cute they look good
they're making money on Instagram
okay
because they carry the weight right
well and the thing is that to a to a
degree like no matter what you look like
there's always going to be somebody out
there that's going to be into that right
you know what I mean and then then you
go into the into the from the female
point of view there are some women that
you know
they fantasize about a dude that has a
Ferrari and a whole bunch of money they
got that
they got some women that [ __ ]
fantasize about they're just size queens
they just want [ __ ] big old dick
the thing is there's not that many of
them
and that might just be a fantasy
when they meet the dude like that they
don't might not really hook up with that
dude because oh yeah that's all he's got
is that big old dick that's what I'm
saying because well that's kind of the
problem too is that a lot of times and I
don't know I don't have a huge amount of
experience in this area yeah but um you
know what I mean it's just kind of like
because you know it's I've only had like
a handful of boyfriends she hasn't been
in my entire life I mean it's it's some
but not that many
but the thing about it is that sometimes
and I'm going to by experience of like
you know uh female friends of mine
sometimes guys that have like really
really big dicks one it's just kind of
like sometimes you don't want to and
this made me laugh because I think this
is a quote from The Witches of Eastwick
where uh where one of I think it was
Susan Sarandon and she said that her
husband was huge and she's like there's
just some nights I just couldn't face it
so you know what I mean so it's like
yeah sometimes you're just like really I
just I just can't deal with it right now
so I get that
um but also I kind of feel like dudes
that have super big dicks they're just
kind of like hey I have a big dick
that's all they're gonna do and then
that's it it's like so I can be a jerk
the rest of the time it's like hey big
dick you know what I mean like that's
their one claim to be the full package
yeah so it's like if you have a big dick
but you are also an a-hole and you know
how to dress and you don't know how to
dress and you don't know how to act and
[ __ ] like that is not gonna do you any
good and you don't have a job yeah and
you can't help pay a bill
it's a problem you gotta try to fight
you got to try to fill all the [ __ ]
you got to try to fulfill all the
[ __ ] prerequisites it's got to be
reasonable yeah you got to be reasonable
we gotta be practical if you're not
practical you ain't gonna make it yeah
no a woman a woman older than [ __ ] 22
is going to want a practical
[ __ ] because you gotta help pay
bills well you need somebody you can
rely on yeah right you don't need
somebody that's gonna like clean out
your bank account and then go bang
hookers and buy a Coke and [ __ ] like
that and be like where the [ __ ] did this
[ __ ] he stole my car like you
know what I mean because some dudes will
do that yeah and you'll be gone in a
[ __ ] heartbeat big dick and all yeah
you uh you want some of that uh orange
or you rather have uh some more of the
uh I guess I'll have some more of the
peach I mean because I kind of want
another mixed drink because I don't want
to get too [ __ ] up you know what I
mean
I mean yeah they're saying that but I
don't know it's just like I said you
know we've said this on the show many
times everybody
well with some exceptions I'm sure but
everybody has something to offer you
know what I mean and if you have
something good to offer then everything
else can be worked with but you can't
just sit back like oh I have a big dick
or oh you know I'm beautiful like if
you're a woman or something like that
um and that's like all you got you gotta
have some other [ __ ] to like back that
up because you know
big dick eventually you might get
erectile dysfunction if you're young and
beautiful eventually that's not going to
stick around either because you're going
to get old like everybody does and so
you really have to have like something
else to back that up you know other than
just kind of like physical stuff
otherwise no one's going to want to hang
with it for you because we're going to
Rarity and [ __ ] ing yeah okay well
that's okay I mean these are super super
sweet anyway so and I might have to come
up with uh
something to eat before we leave I don't
know yeah we probably should if not
we'll stop by Circle K and get a damn
microwave sandwich
because you know we're gonna try to hit
those on the way back
isn't it funny that like every time we
go predict this [ __ ] I've always just
kind of like let's stop at Circle K I
wanna they they don't get a burrito get
a cricket burrito Cricket meat burrito
see I don't like the burritos from there
I don't well I don't want um I mean they
have the cold sandwiches there they have
like actually a really decent it's
chicken salad with cranberries in it
yeah and it's actually pretty decent and
like the ones I've got I got ones there
at like two or three in the morning and
the bread is like super fresh yeah so
I'm just gonna Circle K's got good
sandwiches they do yeah well like I said
you can't really
um yeah slack off anymore it's not like
the old days like the 70s and 80s where
you'd stop a convenience store and like
the [ __ ] sandwiches have been there
for like four weeks and like had mold on
the outside and [ __ ] like that uh
grafter said question have you ever had
a random hookup and then soon regretted
it you know they were missing teeth or
stank or were low IQ or were cross-eyed
no all right
um not me no no no I see all this I mean
I've had I've regretted a couple things
but not much no here's the thing man you
can regret a hottie
she could be hot but then you're like
managed to never [ __ ] that band you know
she never really [ __ ] around with that
sure
but I don't think I don't I've never
been in a situation where
where I got and I picked up like dudes
at bars before but a couple of times but
I never got in a situation where it's
like I'm going out to each other we were
just [ __ ] hanging out and [ __ ]
[ __ ] cheap pickup dudes I'd pick up
the chicks
you guys don't understand how Wild it
was uh there's one of them that [ __ ]
that I regretted messing with because
she was [ __ ] crazy Susan
yeah yeah and she was cute Susan's real
cute well she's still around she's still
around I saw her she's crazy a couple
weeks ago she's crazy I haven't talked
to her in a while though but I saw her
she's not as bad as she was yeah I think
she's kind of settled yeah but when she
was when she was younger back in those
days that was a long time ago uh that
was before me and you and [ __ ] now
yeah I mean she's she was around and
then like she wasn't around for a long
time but she's just recently started
coming back out again she looks almost
exactly the same yeah she does she is
back in the old days she looks like she
hasn't aged today no I had a 10 days a
day we gosh man we don't we don't age
yeah I mean we do but just more slowly
than she's not a crazy than regular folk
well like I said she went through some
bad [ __ ] she did and it's like I I kind
of felt bad for her to be honest with me
murder Hornet said I'm hung like a
mosquito
yeah and honestly to be honest I had I'm
not advocating like uh just going out
picking up people in bars because a lot
of times that can go horribly wrong but
I mean I did it a few times and it
turned out okay I didn't get murdered or
you know and most of the guys that were
fine it was fine except that one well
except that one yeah when you chased his
ass off I was there all right we're
sitting out there in a [ __ ] I started
chasing dude officers that [ __ ]
there man's just trying to go anal
what's going on
some of you guys are which is fine but
like ask first them
okay don't just wow
y'all [ __ ] some crazy [ __ ] you know
what I mean [ __ ] one time we over the
years we
me and Jenny talking [ __ ] and I'm
talking [ __ ] sometimes you have somebody
in the audience because Jenny don't you
get jealous you go you don't know the
[ __ ] half of the [ __ ] they'd be in
jail been through all right you don't
know
I used to I think but like maybe a
little bit but it's a reason why me and
Jen better get a probably 10 over 10
years probably 11 12 years now huh uh we
just got together and well okay we first
met yeah in 2009 yeah 2010. we didn't
start going out until like mid 2011.
yeah I think so it's been 11 years yeah
yeah just just past 11 years yeah me and
Jenny Never Would Have Made It if we
weren't friends
and that's really a key thing
you know yeah people go out with each
other they're not even [ __ ] friends
and that [ __ ] blows up within [ __ ]
six months you know
maybe in general France before we
started going out yeah so that makes a
big difference it just kind of happened
like very organically because like I
said we were at first we were just like
hanging out because we liked each other
yeah but we were dating other people
yeah like off and on she was married
when I first met her yeah that's right
and then like I got divorced and then we
kind of hung out and then we kind of
hooked up and then we were hanging out
we hooked up a little bit but then that
kind of broke off and then we were
[ __ ] did business together for a
while and then you were kind of and then
you were kind of saw somebody else and I
was like seeing like another guy and
another couple guys or something like
that because and then we just kind of
ended up yeah together just by a process
of evolution and everybody and Oliver
it's funny because like all of our
friends because sometimes we would just
go out to the bar like together like one
of us would drive the other person it's
not I'd be I'd sleep over at his house
it's like he'd sleep over at my
apartment [ __ ] like that and people are
like would you guys just go out already
like what the [ __ ] are you even doing
like everybody was just like waiting
they're like come on now anytime you
know it was just kind of like that yeah
it was like super funny
but I don't know but yeah it was just
kind of like that guy was okay though
okay that he was he was okay I don't
mean to I don't mean to like yeah I
remember he was an okay dude but yeah
like in hindsight like well at the time
that it happened I was just kind of like
what the [ __ ] dude like what are you
even doing like and I mean to his credit
like when I said uh what are you doing
like hey knock that off and then he did
stop so like he didn't keep going but I
was just kind of like like I said I'm
not averse to it I'm just saying it's
like hey ask me you can't just [ __ ]
jumping up in the booty like that that's
what I it's like Jesus Christ come on
now this
I mean I have a little bit of like
etiquette you know I'm just like dude I
don't even know you
you guys I just like I was at
kind of feel like it was a Halloween
party because I think he had like a
costume on well it wasn't like a costume
costume but it was like kind of a drive
because I liked it oh wait now we're
talking about different dudes I remember
dude you told Mom yeah
I thought you were talking about a
little [ __ ] kind of like almost kind
of a redneck looking Dude that [ __ ]
was like a little short
because I saw you chase his ass off that
was a different guy yeah it was a
different guy okay but uh yeah all right
that was a different okay
I was out front and I saw Jenny Chase
his ass off and I said yeah he's a loser
okay that was a picture because I know a
loser want to see one
granther said do Goths age better
because they avoid harmful sun rays for
other reasons well that's probably a big
reason uh no
that's probably a reason I don't think
so
because look you know I think a lot of
people we know are [ __ ] they had not
aged that well
yeah it's not across the board because
we do know some people that have been in
the god scene a long time that do look
there are people there there are people
that are younger than us that look 20
years older
overweight yeah it depends on how much
do they drink drugs drinking drugs
uh lifestyle [ __ ] up lifestyle right
yeah
so I think it's kind of like a lot I
mean I'm sure staying out of the sun
does help uh because you don't get like
all the [ __ ] Sunburn and wrinkles and
everything like that but
you know what I mean but a lot of it
happens
you do I don't genetics that yeah I
think that's genetics and fun I think
that's also a factor ego has a lot to do
with it
because like I said even if yeah like
because and I've said this before but my
mom
who is nearly 70 she's 68.
um she still looks quite young and she
actually
um went out in the sun a lot because she
was real into like going to the beach
and stuff I wasn't I was like even when
she would take me to the beach when I
was a kid I'm like I'm gonna go sit
under the pier yeah so I like in the
shadow because I didn't want to get like
a tan or anything a lot of golf people
are egotistical in vain a lot of them
so they fight harder all right they'll
dye it they'll do
performance enhancing drugs they'll
[ __ ] get surgery or whatever it takes
and wear the right clothes and
stay yeah they want to maintain a
particular look as long as possible
that's a lot of it it's like wearing
some corsets and wigs and you're right
trying to not overeat and
uh
eventually working out
because you can't stay skinny and then
get old you're going to get pot belly
especially if you're a man
sometimes women's figures which they age
is a little bit more forgiving but it
depends on the build
but eventually when you hit 50 you're
just gonna have to [ __ ]
you're gonna have to use technology
and hard work it's just that's just goes
with it you know that's why that's why
actors and actresses [ __ ] celebrities
that's why a lot of them look real good
you think that's natural that's not
natural
they're taking stuff and I can get it
[Music]
and stuff like that right and uh
stylists right and if you're in the Golf
Scene you're going to know all the drug
dealers you can get anything you want
if you're in a decent place
I can get anything
Danny Rowling said smoking and drinking
and kids will Aid you real quick yeah
that might have been a thing to you
that's part of it I never had anything a
lot of Goths don't have kids or if they
do have kids they don't worry about them
I mean they do but they want yeah but
they still have their own lives they
don't like you know they they
compartmentalize one of the one of the
best looking goth girls that we know is
a friend of Jenny's her name is Jen too
she's a vocalist from 13th Angel her
name is Jen Draven you guys can Google
her she's got two daughters that are
gorgeous that are grown they're grown
daughters that are gorgeous
yeah her daughters are what 18 and 20
and 20 something something 22 21 yeah
you would never [ __ ] you would never
know they all look like they're say all
look like they're the same they all look
like they're sisters and they're not the
same age yeah yeah it kills me it kills
me
but yeah I just when I because I've
known Jen for probably like seven eight
years at this point and when she told me
that she had two grown daughters I mean
well when we first met her like her
younger daughter was
12 or 13. yes but she's grown now she's
18 19. yeah it is she's going out to the
club now yeah her and her boyfriend go
to the club with uh
with uh Mom and Dad Jenna Dimitri
yeah goes out with them that's Jen
she's got two grown daughters there and
that's exactly what she looks like she
looks exactly like a special photo or
anything and her daughters look to be
the same age as her
see if I can find
that's a very natural shot of her no
makeup or anything that's how she looks
I mean it's very very Whited out uh I'm
gonna try to get it there there you go
yeah that's where she lives and that's
like I said that's exactly she looks
like that just walking around yeah
that's exactly what she looks like
she's
um a little bit younger than me but
not much younger see if I can find
pictures of her and her daughters
she's in her 40s yeah yeah pushing 50 I
think she might be because I think like
a few I remember a few years ago and she
said that she was 38 and that was like a
while back a long time ago so she's like
in her mid-40s I think there's one
daughter
only said is that a wig or her hair no
that's her hair that's her hair yeah
that's her older daughter
and the younger daughter is just as cute
yeah she doesn't wear wigs hmm
she just has like very very straight
it's usually black but she does like uh
red and blue sometimes
like just streaks
so it's funny that's like somebody's mom
you know it's just funny to think about
yeah it is
but like I said it's our lives that's we
know I think the thing that's kind of
refreshing about the goth scene is that
okay look even when they go that's all
three of them it's all three of them
there you go that's a good picture
that's that's recent yeah that's her and
her daughters yeah
and they and they show up to the club
and it looks like a pack of sisters
yeah yeah
that's a recent pick because her that's
her daughter looks just like that
because I just saw her a couple weeks
ago
she came out
but um that's the thing I kind of feel
like a lot of them do have kids but they
don't because sometimes I feel like when
people have kids and I'm not saying that
you shouldn't do this like if this is
kind of what you want to do then you
know then do it I'm not [ __ ] on you
but I'm just saying that sometimes when
people have kids that's like their whole
life is like upended it's like now my
whole entire life is going to be
revolved around this kid which is cool
to an extent but it's like you're still
a person and you still have to have your
your own life and your own happiness and
stuff like that so I kind of feel like
maybe some people in The Goth scene are
kind of better at like
compartmentalizing that it's like
they'll have kids and it's fine but it's
like you know once a month I'm Gonna
Leave the kid with a babysitter and put
on all my gosh [ __ ] and go out and dance
and have a good time and drink and stuff
like that and it's fine it's you know it
makes them happier
so I don't know I kind of feel like but
people maybe
better uh balance with that maybe like
between family and
lifestyle I don't know we'll go to the
restroom
how much time do we have
before what before we have to start
getting ready it's only 7 30.
talking about the drug war hey Rebecca
what's up
good to see you
talking about Mexico which I've never
been so I can't really
Tom and Jenny gonna watch the new Hocus
Pocus 2. I thought about it okay so
um in case you were like I went with my
sister
to Disney last Sunday she brought me she
bought me a ticket for the Disney
Halloween party whatever last Sunday and
we went
um for my birthday
and she
uh we were talking about Hocus Pocus
because one of the things that they did
for the Halloween they did was like this
big show like in front of the castle
um you know the Cinderella castle that
had the Sanderson sisters they were kind
of like hosting it and then it was all
these villains and songs and stuff
and uh she had already seen it my sister
had already seen it
and I was kind of like should I watch it
is it worth it because me and my sister
were seven years apart she's seven years
younger than me but we used to joke with
one another that we like shared a brain
because
we're like into a lot of the same [ __ ]
and we'll like finish each other's
sentences and stuff but I was like is it
should I like bother watch it she's like
well
she's like it's fan service she's like
there's nothing wrong with that but
she's like I don't know they were she's
like there was some funny [ __ ] in it but
it just seemed like oh of course like
that was kind of the movie I'll probably
watch it but
I don't know Tom probably won't watch I
don't even think Tom saw the first uh
the first Hocus Pocus and I get like I
love Hocus Pocus but I have to be in the
right mood to watch it because it is a
little
frenetic uh and it is a little kind of
like geared toward a younger audience
which is fine but I have to really
really be like vibing like to watch it
like that because it's a little bit over
caffeinated for me let's put it like
that it's a little bit over the top but
uh but it's good otherwise but yeah she
said like the second one was okay but it
was just kind of like more of the same
and it was just like obviously you know
cashing in on everything so you know
uh Danny Rowling said I heard Kathleen
to Jimmy uh was the only funny thing
about the film
um my sister like described this one
scene to me that I was like well that
sounds pretty funny but it's like maybe
that's the funniest thing in the movie
and then she ruined it for me I don't
really do but I probably will get around
so maybe I'll watch it on like around
Halloween or something like that and
maybe I'll talk about it on the show
just to see I'm kind of curious to watch
it but okay look we're gonna shut it
down around eight so we have an hour to
get ready and then we'll leave it around
nine because I gotta cook us some food
all right I'm not gonna drink much more
okay
so I'll be fine for the bride there and
back okay okay
see everybody's saying uh blurter dude
said show idea classic popular or lesser
known Halloween specials for TV examples
being peanuts and Garfield maybe we
should do that for a kind of well
Halloween falls on a Monday this year
which is like a haunt which is like a
haunting show but I don't know maybe we
should do like a Halloween special
instead and we can kind of talk about
that because I kind of feel like they
did do a lot of cool like Halloween
episodes of things
that we could probably talk about I mean
the peanuts one is obviously the best
one but
every you know what and I don't think
I've ever seen anybody dress up as a
costume like this but I thought about it
like a few times I said wouldn't it be
cool and this would actually be like a
really cheap costume too it would be
cool to dress up like Charlie Brown from
the Halloween special so all you have to
do is get yourself uh like a holy sheet
you know I mean like a sheet with a
bunch of holes in it and then get a bag
with a bunch of rocks in it because he
went around in the sheet was supposed to
be a ghost but all he had was like a
sheet that was full of holes so
everybody was like [ __ ] on them by
instead of giving him candy they've like
put rocks into his bag so I was just
like I thought that would be like a
really funny Halloween costume but I've
never seen anybody do it I'm sure
somebody has but
I was gonna do it but I never did
uh let's see
It's the Great Pumpkin Charlie Brown
yeah
I like all the peanut specials like the
Halloween one is good the Thanksgiving
one is good and I feel like nobody talks
about that one uh but Thanksgiving one
is also fun and obviously the Christmas
one is like a [ __ ] classic
uh Danny Rowling said when good ghouls
go bad starring Christopher Lloyd was a
decent Halloween film sort of like My
Bloody Valentine but with zombies all
right I kind of like that one that had
Tim Curry in it what was it the worst
witch
it's like so so cheesy but I don't know
I kind of loved it I kind of loved it
no man like I'd
such a fun time at Disney like for the
Halloween thing because you know it's
Disney so they're gonna go like all out
right and me and my sister were there
and I just like I was like I was totally
Dorking out about it like we were
walking around like oh my God I love
Halloween so much and it was just gonna
because they just did the whole park out
there was like little glowing
jack-o-lanterns everywhere and like
little Mickey heads that were like
shaped like pumpkins and all this other
kind of stuff and all the rides had like
crazy like scary lights on them and they
like some of the rides they did like
different [ __ ]
you know what I mean and they had uh
people with they had like these big huge
barrels of candy like a big huge barrels
of candy that were almost as tall as a
person and they gave you a bag and like
you just went around and you could go
and get as much candy as you wanted like
all night long as long as you saw like
one of those so [ __ ] man I saw some of
the kids like his parents were taking
their kids there and some of those kids
had like [ __ ] bags and bags just full
of candy they're just giving you free
[ __ ] candy like all night long I
couldn't eat all that candy we were too
busy like going on the rides anyway
because I told my sister she goes to
Disney every year because she loves
Disney
she just lives in Atlanta so she comes
down every year and does like a she
stays in the resort and goes to all the
polite gets the park hopper thing and
because she'd been to Animal Kingdom
that same day that like we went to
Disney because we went in the evening
but I was like I haven't been to Disney
in like a million years so I was like
just I said I want to go on everything
because I can't
like even [ __ ] that I just went on as a
kid because I didn't remember like a lot
of the stuff so I was like I want to see
what it's all like now so we went on
pretty much everything we actually
wanted to go on the Haunted Mansion
twice we went on earlier in the day that
was the longest wait because it was the
Halloween thing so everybody was like
Haunted Mansion Haunted Mansion so we
got on that at first and then we were
gonna go on it again later but
apparently everyone else had the same
idea so when we got over there the line
was like [ __ ] huge and long we were
like [ __ ] that so we just like
I wanted it because they had like live
actors like out front like later on but
I didn't get to see any of that but we
went on like other [ __ ] too like we went
on Splash Mountain we went on Space
Mountain which like I said they turned
all the lights off and that was
terrifying
um and they did we even went on like the
little kids we went on it's a small
world we went on Peter Pan we went on
the Winnie the Pooh rag we went on
everything
it's like super fun
you know what I mean yeah it was super
fun I hadn't been on Peter Pan since I
was a kid
I told her when we were in there
that uh I said isn't this weird I had a
dream
about the Peter Pan ride when I was a
little little kid and I still remember
it
and I said in my dream I was on this
ride but I wasn't because the Peter Pan
ride at Disney you kind of like get in a
thing that looks like a ship but it
flies you know what I mean and it kind
of flies like over this like little city
and like you can see Captain Hook and
all that kind of stuff
and I said so I had this dream that I
was on this ride or something
approximating this ride but I wasn't in
a ship I was actually riding I was
standing upright but I was standing on a
little tiny piece like a little
rectangular piece of like fur
like there was just like a little piece
of fur and I was like standing on it and
it was like flying around and I was like
and I was going over like the crocodile
that comes out of the
floor and [ __ ] like that I said I don't
know why the [ __ ] I drained that
but so it like brought it all back when
I went on that ride again because I've
been on the Run since I was a kid they
don't have the snow white one anymore I
remember the Snow White boom being scary
as [ __ ] they have a snow white adjacent
thing which is the dwarf what is it
called the Seven Dwarfs Mine Train or
something but we didn't get to go on
that because my sister had been on it
but she's like yeah it's not really
worth it so we didn't bother but because
it was getting late and there was like a
show and we wanted to like watch the
parade and everything but I remember
this the Snow White ride at Disney being
like scary I liked it like skip I did
too the snow white or the [ __ ] the
witch came out yeah and that's why I was
just kind of like oh man they don't have
that anymore they don't have that
anymore they like I said they do have
the Mind training little kids don't
deserve that [ __ ] well they still have
but they still have Peter Pan and that's
like some scary [ __ ] in it and they
still have
um they don't have uh Mr Toad anymore
but they replaced Mr Toad with like
Winnie the Pooh but the Winnie the Pooh
ride because I was like well I want to
see this because I used to really like
Mr Toad and I was like I haven't been on
the Winnie the Pooh ride but I actually
like the Winnie the Pooh one like most
of it's kind of cute but
um they did have a whole like Heffalumps
and Woozles room which was actually like
kind of trippy and like disturbing I was
like all right I approve I like this
it's kind of like [ __ ] up like with
the song and everything and it was all
like like a [ __ ] Acid trip and I was
like all right this is cool I like it
but yeah I mean I don't know it was it
was fun and obviously like the Haunted
Mansion
God damn I love that [ __ ] Haunted
Mansion it's just it's so fun and the
thing about it we were talking about
this at the park I said you know
what is kind of a shame it's like I
almost kind of want
to go through the Haunted Mansion like
on foot and just like look at everything
like all the details in there because
there's so much detail I mean that's
true of like all their rides because
they really kind of like put so much
little detail in there that most people
are probably not even going to notice
but it's like I kind of wish that I
could just walk around in there and look
at everything and I was trying to this
time because I've been on it a million
times but this time I was kind of trying
to like look at I'm trying to look at
all the paintings and like all the
because there's all those like little
bitty details and [ __ ] like that and I
said well it'd be cool if you could walk
through like just if you had you know
all the Time in the World to like walk
through but I said in a way I don't want
to do that because it would like
demystify it if you guys go ahead could
go ahead and hit the like button man
that'd help us out so thank you very
much
thank you very much
yeah I'm trying to get our [ __ ]
algorithms better
Hugo said I'm dressing up as Lemmy
killmeister this year
the second time you said that am I
looking like let me hear something I'm
bringing it out of him yeah [ __ ] old
lamby
Jeffy Hart said I love they're talking
about uh peanut specials I love the one
with Snoopy as the Easter Beagle man I
think I only saw that one one time I
barely remember that one Marcy didn't
know how to make Easter eggs much to
Patty's sugar and yeah oh
holy Parish stream said we saw terrifier
2 last night
oh I've been wanting to see that I
really liked the first terrifier
uh Camp guy said what's new with the old
Alien Encounter in Tomorrowland I don't
know what's in there they are building
because we did get on the People Mover
like when we first got there
um just to kind of look at all of
Tomorrowland and stuff I don't know
what's in there but they are building a
massive Tron area they're going to do
like the light cycles and all that kind
of stuff I don't know because I was
asked because my sister knows a bunch of
stuff about Disney because like I said
she loves Disney so I was like it's
right next to if you've ever been to
Disney World
um it's right next to like the
Tomorrowland Speedway where you can like
Drive the little race cars and stuff
and I said well are they incorporating
all of that into the Tron thing or like
are they going to make that into the
light cycle she's like I don't think so
but they're doing like a whole I mean
they were working on it still like it
doesn't look like much of anything now
but they had built like all the top of
it so it's all gonna be like a Tron kind
of thing so I thought that would be kind
of cool but
I don't know and I'm trying to think of
like some of the other stuff that we
went on there and um Splash Mountain
the riot is staying the same because
like we went on Splash Mountain and it's
still Song of the South
um they said it's gonna be this the
ride's gonna be the same but they're
gonna update it to um Princess and the
Frog because that's like a newer and you
know there's already frogs in there so
they don't have to change all that much
I guess but
I had forgotten how fun that ride was
man I got so [ __ ] I got soaking wet
on that [ __ ] my ass was all wet for like
hours and hours like afterwards it was
all the [ __ ] water coming in there
and you know how that's the one where
they take a picture of like when they do
that big drop at the end and I think the
picture it was just me going like that
like trying to get [ __ ] water out of
my face
we got a good I should tell my sister to
send because they send them through your
phone now the pictures
if you have like a pass
and they do pictures on the Haunted
Mansion now too like at the end when
they do the hitchhiking ghosts part they
take a picture of you then and like send
it to you
so we had like a really funny one like
with the [ __ ] ghost sitting in
between us and I was like oh I should
have told her to send it to us she just
got home today
but
yeah it was like it was super fun
um let's see
Danny rolly said Batman Forever takes
place on Halloween kinda
yeah it's like I'm trying to think of
like some I got a couple Halloween
movies and Halloween books like picked
out
for the end of the month like to talk
about but I don't know man I kind of
feel like I already like talked about
most of the best Halloween movies
yeah it's set in current time but the
whole thing feels like an 80s slash or
even some of the soundtrack see that
sounds like right up my alley I mean the
first terrifier was so so good
it was so good
and
the bill oh Bill hinsman oh okay the
first zombie United Living Dead the 88
zombie film takes place on Halloween and
it's free on YouTube I think I might
have seen that um not that I can
remember
not that I can remember now it's
terrifier too is it still is it in
theaters or is it streaming like what's
the deal with that
because I kind of want to watch it now
we have started watching
I think we said the other day we did
start watching um Cobra Kai season five
so we watched what episode are we up to
we watched a bunch of episodes last
night
but I can't remember what episode we're
up to now
I'm really liking this series so far but
I I mean as always the best [ __ ] is
um
the Johnny Lawrence character like the
other I like the other stuff too like
all the stuff with like Miguel and
Danielson and all of that but
I mean William zabka is just like so
he's [ __ ] killing it he's killing it
it's just like so everything that every
time that he's in the show and it's all
about like how stuck in the 80s he is
and he doesn't know how Uber works and
he doesn't know how GrubHub works and
it's like he doesn't have a cell phone
and he's like calling Google goggle and
stuff like that it's like every that
just kills me every [ __ ] time I love
it I love it
he's like the best part he's the best
part and it's uh it's funny because I
never would have thought that in a
million years
never would have thought that in a
million years that he would be like the
best part of any show and I cannot
believe that Cobra Kai got seriously
every [ __ ] that was in the
original any one of the original like
Karate Kid movies for like five seconds
they got them back like to be in the new
show I mean as long as they're still if
they're still alive but they got like
all of them back everybody
it's crazy it's crazy
uh Louis says Jenny have you seen the
trailer for the new Let the Right One In
series I have not I have not
uh Danny Rowling said Donnie Darko takes
place on Halloween it does but we
already did Donnie Darko we already
talked about Donnie Darko
uh oh and he also says Stephen King's
Silver Bullet you know what we should
probably do Silver Bullet one of these
days
I don't think we've done Silver Bullet
have we the Stephen King adaptation no
no I don't think so with Gary Busey you
love Gary Busey and he is at Peak Gary
Busey in that movie
I like Silver Bullet I don't care what
anybody says
I remember actually
um because it started out as like a
graphic novel
and I used to check that out that I
never I never bought it but I used to
check it out of the library all the time
you gonna talk so I can go to the
bathroom go ahead and go ahead and go to
the bathroom
I'm just trying to kill time I don't
really want to talk about Disney or
anything
um the uh
I'm getting ready to get out of this
[ __ ]
we're gonna go to the club tonight
so I'm seeing what everybody else is
doing hold on
but uh I'm [ __ ] starving I want to
get some uh
breakfast sandwiches
I might have to run up to them
Circle K just go buy something and bring
it back here microwave it I got food
downstairs I even got breakfast out I
don't have any bread I don't have the
bread that I need
I want some uh
uh what do you call them English muffins
Rebecca Zan
she said Silver Bullet was our Friday uh
night staple movie uh with Lost Boys And
Silence of the Lambs yeah yeah
they're good movies
Adriana's in what's up Adriana
and she she says was Karate Kid as huge
in the 80s as it is now
okay
the thing with Karate Kid
Karate Kid came in a time when VHS was
real popular
I was in high school at that time
you could get Karate Kid you could not
only could you uh
rent it like Blockbuster you could
bootleg it so you'd have copies of it
and you'd watch it over and over
because it was
um
it was of your age group it was about
being in high school so Karate Kid okay
it was huge
but you wouldn't have known it at the
time if you were an adult adults weren't
watching it it was teenagers and people
in high school that were watching over
and over again
and they made three movies
you know three Karate Kid movies and I
saw them all they were all good
we like to
um I gotta say a television series is in
a way better but it was all I I agree
but it was all built on those three
movies even though those three movies
were ridiculous only the first two were
but see that's what's awesome about the
show is that it acknowledges it
acknowledges the whole premise of the
movie was ridiculous it was fantasy but
it kind of like and the thing about it
too is that I think the reason why it
works is because it's kind of poking fun
at the fact that it was ridiculous but
it's also really Earnest yeah like it's
taking it seriously grown man with
karate come on yeah
come on they kind of that's what I mean
it's like and they they got the right
balance of like they're kind of like
lamp shading it a little bit it's just
like yeah we know this is a ridiculous
premise and stuff like that but they're
also taking it really seriously and I
think like they got the balance just
right and the thing about it is that I
saw Karate Kid
when I was you know that age when I was
a teenager it wasn't my favorite though
like I liked it but I was more into
there was other movies the John Hughes
movies and you know better off dead with
John Cusack and like I liked stuff like
that like valley girl with Nicholas he
liked Karate Kid we were black and also
Terminator one yeah well that too I'm
just talking about I'm talking about
like teen movies yeah as far as that
goes there's a bunch of other stuff
going on at the time yeah and during
last time that was another lab and I was
really into during this time if you were
a boy
you were probably hanging out at
7-Eleven because you couldn't go to a
[ __ ] nightclub
the 7-Eleven had video games that were
karate [ __ ]
um themed one of them I think was called
Kung Fu or something might have been
called karate
where you know you had karate yeah
karate game you had a guy in a white
ghee and then a guy in a red gee and if
we could fight begin and [ __ ] it was
like some of the very first fighting
games so like Mortal Kombat but produce
before that and then you also had like
Shinobi coming in
you've got that on your Xbox don't you
yeah
yeah so and then ghosts and goblins and
[ __ ] like that gauntlet
so there was a big martial arts
[ __ ] influence in teen culture at
that time yep and you're hanging out at
7-Eleven and there's a right behind the
you're playing these [ __ ] video games
Spy Hunter and stuff
and behind you is a magazine rack and in
that magazine rack is like guns and ammo
and also like Kung Fu
and karate magazines
there was no internet
so you didn't know what was true you
know you didn't know and and karate was
making some [ __ ] incredible claims
that they could throw cheese balls and
knock people over with Chi power
and I'd seen some weird [ __ ] you know in
the Paranormal range you know in terms
of [ __ ] poltergeists and [ __ ] like
that so I thought maybe
maybe karate could do that too Sierra
it was just another time you could lie
and get away with some some [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] back in those days even
before
a lot of the stuff about Bruce Lee
wasn't true
so this stuff is all mythical it's
mythological
and uh you're not sure what's actually
physical you're not really sure what's
physically possible or not
and karate was part of that and I was
gonna say in in regards to whether
Karate Kid was really big in the 80s I'm
gonna say that
um not just like the Kung Fu magazines
but you also had like the teen girl like
Bop and Teen Beat and they're beating
all that kind of [ __ ] and Ralph Macchio
was all over that [ __ ] yeah all over
that [ __ ] so yeah he was on the covers
of all the stuff so yeah it was a big
deal like I said I I wasn't real into it
because like I said he looked even
though I was probably like the same age
as him but he still looked like a kid to
me it was a lesbian thing and that was I
wasn't so and I liked Karate Kid but it
wasn't my favorite like I said teen
movies when I was growing I was really
into when I was a teenager I was really
into like the John Hughes movies I
really liked Pretty in Pink and uh
Breakfast Club and some kind of
wonderful I liked all those yeah I liked
valley girl from like the early 80s
Ralph Macho looked like a Butch lesbian
back in those days well he looked like
kit I mean
I kind of feel like
well what I thought like when he would
be on the cover of the magazines and
stuff like that because at that point I
was like 16 or something like that I was
like he looked like younger than me it
was some gender Banning [ __ ] he looked
younger than me yeah so it's the same
with [ __ ] Michael J fox plus I was
more into like Duran Duran yeah you know
what I mean Michael J fox was big before
that
uh about a year or so before that girls
[ __ ] liked him and it was always
these kind of [ __ ] little cute guys
that they were but that was that Teen
Beat type magazines yeah you know I used
to see the covers of those like in the
yeah
like I said I'd buy them if they had
Duran Duran in there yeah but but uh
yeah it was just a funny time the CR the
karate angle
was kind of like
paranormal promise
uh you had small guys in their teenage
years
clutching onto this [ __ ] fantasy that
maybe a small guy could beat up a big
guy that's what [ __ ] that was the
selling point of kung fu
now can a small guy beat up a good big
guy
no
no not in general and under certain
circumstances yeah but if a dude could
pick you up
he can beat your ass
that's why children don't be beat up
adults
because the adult is really really drunk
yeah right
yeah it's difficult to get around Mass
when it comes to like in mechanics with
cars a motorcycle
they have a they have a saying called
there is no replacement for displacement
and that's true
if you got a motorcycle that's [ __ ]
400 1400 cc's a [ __ ]
five valve per cylinder [ __ ]
motorcycle
a 250 is not going to beat it there is
no you can put all the superchargers and
turbochargers that you want there is no
replacement for displacement it's the
same with dudes
for dudes [ __ ] six foot one [ __ ]
weighs 2 [ __ ] 20 pounds of pure
muscle
and you're five five and we have 145
pounds you don't [ __ ] stand a chance
that dude's gonna
that dude's gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
you karate or not
that's what karate was about
it was this weird [ __ ]
it was this weird paranormal promise
that a small guy could beat up a big guy
which is like the kind of
that's a Japanese fantasy you know
that's where that comes from well it's
kind of like any dude that's kind of
small I guess never gets picked on
that's like anything that's any fantasy
that they have it's like I'm gonna get
back at like all the bullies like guys
that are bigger than me
if you go back and look at Bruce Lee
and
uh who was chinese-american and kung fu
and then you can go into karate with the
Japanese guys in the 60s and the 70s
they would not fight a western fighter
they would make up a bunch of excuses
why they won't fight a western fighter
because that [ __ ] wouldn't have worked
proof was in the pudding there's a
Chinese guy who's an MMA fighter who is
the size and the weight of a western MMA
fighter and he was going in China
[ __ ] challenging these [ __ ] 60
year old Tai Chi Masters that said that
they could [ __ ] knock you down with
cheese balls and all that and there's
videos of this dude just going beating
the [ __ ] out of those dudes
all right mental powers and [ __ ]
she-balls and speed won't help you okay
it's not what fighting's about
Mass has a lot to do with it mass and
strength
so
your karate fantasy goes out the window
with that you said well skill and speed
yeah it might help you a little bit but
not over time
not over time
fights always involve [ __ ] just a and
they end up on the ground in submission
holds
where
strength and Mass have a lot to do with
it okay I'm off that subject Danny
Rowling said as big as ninjas were in
the 80s they should revamp the ninja
movies
ninjas need to come back
uh mastille says my favorite 80s movie
as a kid was Wes Craven's shocker I
remember that one yeah when they jump
into the TV and are fighting in the new
studio World War II Etc seemed so cool
to me soundtrack was also good we should
probably review that because I haven't
seen that in a long time Adriana c said
John Cusack and James Spader looked fine
back in the day they did James Spader is
like an attractive man but every time
like I guess I kind of got he was
attractive to me but not because of the
[ __ ] characters that he always played
he always played like the quintessential
Yuppie [ __ ] I guess it's just because
of him being like uh in Pretty in Pink
and I was just like man I just want to
punch that dude right in the [ __ ]
dick but John Cusack I love I love John
Cusack and like I would watch anything
that he didn't like say anything was
great better off dead was great if you
haven't seen better off dead from I
think it was 1985. please watch that I
love that [ __ ] movie so much it's so
good I saw like a million times like
back in the day
um yeah they're talking about uh
shokosugi Enter the Ninja pray for death
all that kind of stuff yeah I can just
like [ __ ] ninjas man it was like
ninja moving break dancing movies
anything that was like any kind of like
[ __ ] see Louie's in there he knows
exactly what I'm talking about he says
he used to hang out at 7-Eleven reading
the [ __ ] Kung Fu magazines yes that's
right Louie it was a universal consonant
and
well old school
7-Eleven playing yeah joust or whatever
game they had because they switched them
out they had they only had two like in
the back room so whatever one they had
sometimes it was sometimes it was Miss
Pac-Man it was just depend on like some
of the machines are broken and then
they're bringing another one blah blah
so you go in there you go in there you
get your [ __ ] Snoopy chocolate pie
you'd go in there and you play joust or
whatever now we did as we did a a show
on ninjas
it didn't get very many hits it wasn't
really that show really was entitled
correctly people didn't really watch it
um ninjas did not exist
they just didn't
not anything like what you see in the
movies it's a myth yeah the Japanese
thought they existed back in the 1700s
1800s they thought ninjas existed
but they're reading stuff from centuries
before and kind of misunderstanding it
the the closest you'll ever get to a
ninja is uh there's some Japanese
historical writings that involve an
attack on a certain castle and that some
Shinobi were used to do some stuff but
what they're describing is nothing more
than just
normal Soldier tactics of raiding
outposts and using arson to weaken up an
enemy fortification before an attack
based on that and a bunch of other stuff
the Japanese started to imagine
things like Shinobi which ended up
becoming ninja as having near
Supernatural powers
but they never existed it was like a a
mythological creature
from Japanese folklore
and there was no there were no Ninjutsu
Clans back in those days that
the Japanese of the [ __ ] like
Tokugawa period which would be like late
1700s 1800s imagined that that stuff had
once existed but it didn't
already went through that
yep yeah Danny Rowling is talking about
the octagon with Chuck Norris yeah
actually that was of all the Chuck
Norris movies that have ever been made
of which I think I've seen every single
one of them which you know for reasons
that I've gone into previously
um the Octagon that's like the second
one that I would watch actually the only
one that I would actually watch again
willingly was silent rage because that
was actually like a horror movie and
that was actually like pretty good it
was like a serial killer but the Octagon
is pretty good too that's like my second
favorite
not a fan of all the ones that I that I
don't like
um Rebecca said I had a crush big time
on Michael dudikoff in the early 90s
when he was in Cobra such a bad show but
he was so pretty that's my embarrassing
moment for the show today Danny's asking
about what about the eager ninjas and
Ninja Villages all that stuff is later
it's mythology that came later after
after the stories of Shinobi and ninja
there were no ninja
okay there were Shinobi but Shinobi has
something to do with I don't remember
the exact Japanese word it meant Special
Operations you're talking about
Special Operation mercenary soldiers
doing very common soldierly duties
nighttime raid
sensory removal arson
Terror tactics is with a Tama but it
wasn't
some kind of a clannous secretive
organization or a mafia or anything like
that it was normal professional Soldier
activities for all heiress every Soldier
did that it just happened to be called
uh a Shinobi attack or in other words a
special operations attack a raid that's
what they're talking about
um but no there weren't any there were
stories of stuff like that but they were
always Shinobi this and that and [ __ ]
special because here's the problem
let's say you're a warlord
and you're trying to attack another
Warlord
why the hell would you spend good money
on some kind of weird clan of dudes that
you don't know if you can trust or not
when you have your own soldiers that you
know you can trust and you can have them
do it and that's just the way
professional Warfare is you don't hire
mercenaries to do stuff like that when
you got your own guys your own guys go
do it
and what they were being asked was not
anything really special nighttime raid
that's all it is
now that would have been a big deal to
the [ __ ] Samurai because the samurai
class
we're kind of honor bound and they had a
bunch of rules like yo you know you have
to [ __ ] clearly delineate when combat
starts and when it ends and it has to
happen during daylight hours and it's
got to be fair and square face you know
face we got to face each other on the
battlefield all honorable and [ __ ]
Special Operations are not like that
it's let's go there the day before and
we'll soften them up we'll set some [ __ ]
on fire
so tomorrow when we have the big fight
they won't have all their supplies ready
you're going to use your own guys to do
that the nighttime raid you're not going
to use some kind of exotic
mercenary you don't need them your guys
can handle that so that that's that's
one of the big things against this ninja
thing and then when some people say well
the ninjas though they were good at
psychological warfare and raping people
and stuff because that's
part of the Ninja lore you could also
have your own guys doing that you know
you don't need to hire outside help for
that
it's just
no the ninja were mythological
the Japanese thought they were around at
one time but they weren't
they're just talking about soldiers
what fun is that yeah no fun at all yeah
I want ninjas that have those [ __ ]
[ __ ] like a like a motorcycle logo
for Kawasaki but that's what it was
that's where they got yeah the uh movie
the actual black ninja outfit actually
comes from Japanese theater and those
are the stage hands that set that change
the stages and do things and there was
like evidently some famous Japanese
Opera where those stagehands took swords
and fought a guy on stage and you really
couldn't see him because he Blended in
with the background and it was kind of
like a guy fighting demons or invisible
enemies that doesn't work in real life
black is not a good camouflage if you
wear black in nature you stick out like
a sore thumb what's better is something
kind of like you know marpat or [ __ ]
OD green or [ __ ] coyote
or
you know [ __ ]
what's that damn [ __ ]
[ __ ] that I got over there [ __ ] uh uh
uh [ __ ] jungle uh tiger stripe you
know which is Asian tiger stripe that
works good black is not a good
camouflage
unless you're on a Japanese Opera stage
that's where that [ __ ] came from
all right so are we ready to like yeah
we're gonna shut it down shut it down
yeah it said it's eight o'clock shut
that [ __ ] down don't shut that [ __ ] well
that was like a long time ago but you
kept talking about ninjas okay it's only
six minutes
so yeah so we're gonna uh go and have
something to eat real quick and then I
got about an hour to get ready
and then we're gonna go out and
hopefully it was a cyberpunk party I'm
not doing like a I'm not doing an outfit
or nothing like that I don't have
nothing like that I already know what
I'm gonna wear anyway it'll it'll be
fine it'll be fine but yeah thank you
everybody for hanging out with us this
Friday evening thank you for super chats
please remember to like the video uh
because that does help with the
algorithms so hopefully we'll see you
guys again on Sunday I don't know what
movie we're going to be talking about
it'll be whatever we end up watching
tomorrow night which will depend on
whatever our mood is tomorrow night so
we'll see how it goes but yeah thanks
everybody for hanging out with us this
evening and we will see you guys again
on Sunday afternoon
good night